great news critter junction's game just
got featured as game of the century on
every app store
let's look at how critter junction is
going to handle all of this new traffic
stay tuned
critter junction has done a lot of great
work to be scalable resilient and highly
available
but their traffic is set to increase
exponentially and they're not sure their
current infrastructure can meet those
needs
the biggest problem is that critter
junction's traffic has consistent spikes
as people all over the world log on when
they're in the mood to play with a
virtual pet
with their friends to accommodate this
traffic critter junction allocated more
resources
but was burning money during non-busy
hours still that was better than the
alternative risking service outages by
not allocating enough resources
luckily when critter junction switched
to a microservice architecture
they decided to host their application
on google kubernetes engine
and so they got to use two kubernetes
features that are designed to solve
exactly this
horizontal pod and cluster auto scaling
in kubernetes you can think of a pod as
an application instance
it has one or more containers that are
coupled together and treated as one unit
the horizontal pod auto scaler
automatically adds or removes pods based
on the usage rate of your application
so if a lot of people are currently
using your app and its computational
needs go up it'll add pods for you and
if that uses rates dropped
then auto scaler will automatically
remove pods this happens based on cpu
and memory metrics by default
but it's also possible to use custom
metrics this is great for handling more
requests when you have enough space to
run more pods on
but if there's no space to run
additional pods then even if the
horizontal pod auto scaler wants to add
more
it's out of luck unless you're using
cluster auto scaling
what this does is it adds more resources
to your clusters
in this case machines that pods can run
on
added these features of critter
junctions architecture which did help
alleviate some of the problems but
as we researched more we realized that
in many cases the application would run
out of memory under a heavy load
and there wasn't a really good way to
estimate how much memory was needed
at any given time so we took a different
approach
cluster auto scaler and horizontal pod
auto scaling are both
examples of horizontal scaling or
scaling out
which means they focus on adding more
total resources for the application to
use as a whole
but sometimes it's necessary to scale
vertically or scaling up
by modifying the resource's provision to
an individual service
like if a pod doesn't have enough cpu or
if it has too much ram
that's where gke's vertical pod auto
scaler comes in
vertical pod auto scaler exists to
automatically set up to date resource
limits and requests for the containers
in their pods
it can both down scale pods that are
over requesting resources
and also upscale pods that are under
requesting resources
based on their uses over time this
seemed like a good fit for critter
junction's
problem so we helped them enable the
vertical pod auto scaler on their
cluster
then to get a good baseline for cpu and
memory resources we used vertical pods
auto scaler
sizing recommendations by creating a
vertical pod auto scaler whose update
mode was set to off
finally we updated the deployment to
account for these recommendations
and critter junction was able to run a
lot more efficiently
guessing what resources your app needs
is tricky
but by leveraging horizontal and
vertical auto scaling critter junction
was able to better manage their
workloads become more resilient
and save money on over-allocating
resources all that was left to do was
celebrate their well-earned traffic
boost
so that's a wrap for this episode of
season of scale
stay tuned to learn how critter junction
continues to improve the design of their
app architecture and dev processes
and remember always the architect